The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
RAJESH: My name is Rajesh.
I am one of the
co-founders of ClimateX,
which is some of the groups
who are sponsoring this event.
We are really, really happy
to have a wonderful cast
of speakers, who will be talking
to us about how to turn some
of the work that we have
all done in the field
into advocacy, especially
three kinds of advocacy.
One is a citizen advocacy,
which Nathan and Audrey
will be talking about.
Then there is legal
advocacy, which is Chris.
And advocacy by creating market
solutions, which will be Ory.
So I'm going to get out--
to prove that I'm not Donald
Trump, I'll stop talking now
and give it over
to Chris, who is
going to talk a little bit
about how he, as an MIT chemical
engineer, became a lawyer and
is now going after the bad guys.
CHRIS NIDEL: So as Rajesh
said, my name is Chris.
I'm an attorney in DC.
I do mostly environmental work.
I do some other
pharmaceutical work,
but my background's in
chemical engineering.
So I got a master's degree from
MIT in chemical engineering,
and I use that background to
evaluate chemical exposures,
to evaluate pharmaceutical
exposures, to review--
and review of epidemiology,
and toxicology,
and related scientific subjects
to the cases that I bring.
And as part of that, I
use the whole spectrum
of scientific data.
Some of that is very high
tech, lab-based, mathematical
modeling, obviously, you
know, EPA type sampling.
But then I also use--
at sort of the other
end of the spectrum
is more citizen
science type data.
We'll start by talking about
a few examples starting
with photography, but people
don't think of photography
as being data.
But the same standards
apply in court,
whether it's a sample taken by
an expert with multiple degrees
to a picture taken by
someone on the street corner.
And so, I think photography
is a good starting point
to talk about how to get
things admitted into court,
and how you can use these
types of information, data,
to advocate for your cause--
to prove a case whether it's
to oppose a permit, or to oppose
an expansion of a facility,
or to generate some
finding of liability
on behalf of your client.
So we're going to see if I
can do this with my phone,
and it seems like it's working.
The important thing,
when you start
talking about
scientific evidence,
I get all kinds
of questions where
someone will say,
you know, we're
looking to fight this issue.
We want to go to court,
and we want our data
to be good in court.
So we want data that's the best.
We want it to be good in court.
And the reality
there's no golden rule
for what's admissible in court.
You can have-- I had a case in
Massachusetts outside Boston,
a PCB case where the EPA had
done hundreds and thousands
of sampling testing--
where they had sampled
the ground for PCBs,
and it was all EPA sampling.
It was not part of litigation.
It wasn't done by
me or my experts,
and despite the fact
that it was EPA sampling
done by EPA methods
and protocols,
the defendant still
challenged the data.
I mean, they say, well, it's
not reliable because it was EPA.
So there's no answer
that says, well,
if you do a, b, and c, and
dot all the I's in there,
that it will be admitted.
And I think, to
the other point is,
if you haven't done
a, b, and c, you still
may get your data
in front of the jury
or in front of the
judge, depending
on the assessment of
essentially these factors, which
the first thing is
whether the data is
reliable and repeatable.
So for example, I
had a case, that I'll
give you a couple examples
from, that involved
sampling for bacteria.
It was a chicken house
that had discharges
going to the waters of the US.
It was a Clean Water Act case,
and there was a question about
whether there was bacteria
as well as some nutrients
in the water-- so
phosphorous and nitrogen--
that were polluting
the waterways.
And questions that
become relevant are
is a person wearing
gloves, is there
sterile procedures
used, are the containers
that they're going to take
a sample of the water from--
are they sterile to begin with?
Obviously, if there's any
question about those things,
it calls into question the
reliability and repeatability
of the data.
So that's the first real prong.
The second prong, and
this is pretty loaded,
is whether it's fit for
the intended purpose.
So if you're trying
to prove, for example,
the presence of benzene in
somebody's drinking water,
and you have a certain
test that detects benzene,
and maybe it gives it a number.
If the question for the
jury is whether there
was benzene in the water, there
may be a different standard
than if the question
is was there
enough benzene in the
water for the last 15 years
to give my client leukemia?
And so, there
becomes this question
about what is the
purpose that you're
offering the evidence
for, which then
relates this third point,
which is given your purpose,
is it going to assist the jury?
So if that information,
to whatever degree
it falls in that
scientific rigor spectrum,
how is that going to
help the jury understand?
So maybe we have a test that
shows the presence of benzene,
but we don't trust the number.
But we have an expert that
does groundwater modeling that
can say, well, we
have a number that
shows the presence of benzene.
On top of that,
we have an expert
that modeled out the groundwater
for the last 15 years
and can show the fluctuations
in those concentrations
over the last 15 years--
the combination
of which gives you
the juror or the judge
confidence that there
was, in fact,
benzene in the water,
and it was within a certain
range that, I might argue,
caused a person to get sick.
So with that being
said, let's see.
Oh, do I have--
is it going to be?
Do I not know what I'm doing?
OK.
So here's a simple example.
So I represent-- there's
a lot of people in DC.
There's probably a lot of people
in a lot of different cities.
It's not glamorous
by any stretch,
but there are a
lot of people that
live in subsidized housing
in this country that
is sub, sub, sub standard.
So there are people
that, whether it's
the state or its HUD,
the federal government,
are paying for them.
In a city like DC,
they're paying,
you know, $1,500 a month
for a mother and her child
to live in conditions that are
unhealthy for both the mother
and for the child, and that
the government's paying
the bill for, and
somebody is profiting
from at the expense
of these people living
in there and at the
expense of the government.
And so, this is an easy example,
where someone takes a picture.
I picked a picture
of this as, you know,
water coming through the
ceiling of this apartment
where you have mold.
We are currently--
I don't know why we're
losing our picture.
Oh, there we go.
So we represent-- in some cases,
we represent the government
on what's called the whistle
blower lawsuit, where we're
representing the government
against these landlords
for collecting money
from the government,
representing that these are
habitable healthy places
that they're getting paid a
significant amount of money
for-- for people to come,
and get sick, and end up
at the emergency room
with asthma attacks
when they can't breathe
anymore, because they've been
living in these conditions.
I could have-- there was
a horrible situation.
And again, it's sort of a
simplified approach to data,
but in one of these
apartments, you go in there,
and there were so many bugs.
I mean, you couldn't--
it was the craziest thing.
But the picture is
worth a thousand words,
and there becomes a
question, like there
would be with any data, as
to who took the picture?
When was it?
Can they certify that
it was in the apartment?
That's at issue.
And at the time-- and, you
know, that they didn't--
it wasn't a bunch of plastic
cockroaches that they put,
but it was in fact a bunch
of bugs crawling around.
Oh, and this, the farmer
trenched the ditch.
So the purpose here would be to
show visible evidence of mold
as opposed to the
farmer trenching
the ditch, which we'll get to.
So you're going to have a
witness that comes in and says,
yeah, I took that picture.
I took it three months ago.
I remember because
it was two weeks
after the water was
dripping from the ceiling,
and here's the mold.
Again, if we were trying to
prove a housing code violation,
the picture is
probably sufficient.
If we're trying to prove that
somebody has asthma attack
two weeks later was caused
by this mold, that's
where you get into some
more sophisticated sampling
and having an
industrial hygienist
come in and do some testing.
So this is another
type of litigation
that I've been involved in.
For those people
that aren't aware,
a good bit of our sewage sludge,
human waste, that we generate
goes from the sewage
treatment plants,
gets collected as solids,
and then gets sent to farms.
In this case, it was a
quote unquote, tree farm,
but it's sent to
farms that grow crops.
And they put human
waste on crops--
the argument being
that it's treated.
The treating is
relatively minimal,
and they essentially put lime
in with the fecal material.
And they then use
it as fertilizer.
So as you can imagine it's
full of pharmaceuticals--
it's full of
industrial chemicals,
because the local industries all
contribute to the sewer system.
There's hospital waste
in there, so there
is viruses, pathogens,
all these things
that you would expect
in human feces--
exist in there.
And in this case, this was a
1,300-acre forest that they
spread this stuff in, and my
client lived in the middle
of the forest.
She ended up with pulmonary
fibrosis with her lungs
that were getting
scarred from repeated
inflammation from breathing
in these proteins and stuff.
And so, this was one of her
pictures of what was going on.
Again, like, not
what we necessarily
think of with respect
to data, but it
creates a compelling
picture, and you still
have that same
standard of getting
it admitted for the court.
This is a picture from the case
that I referenced a little bit
ago.
This is a poultry operation
that we have there
that we had access
on public property.
The water keeper, or
the local river keeper,
had access on public property
to this drainage ditch,
and this is where we get
into sort of a combined
use of different media or data.
The water keeper is able
to come to this ditch
on public property and take
water samples, which she did,
I think, 12 or 14 times.
So she took water
samples, which showed
high levels of bacteria--
fecal coliform, and
E. coli, as well as
high levels of nutrients
going through the ditch,
across the highway,
and then eventually
out into the waters of the US.
And what this photo
actually is is this
is a photo from Google Earth.
It's just a Google
Earth satellite photo.
Another point of issue was,
at the top corner there,
there was a pile of
some unknown material.
And we'll see a close
up in a later picture
that sort of shows some of
what was going on on the farm.
And then you have the pictures
of the chicken houses.
And then you have what's also a
cattle operation in the bottom
right there that I'm going to
show you another picture of it.
So again, this is Google Earth.
We went to trial in this case.
We got these pictures
admitted from Google Earth.
And one of the
things that we saw--
and I was deposing
the defendants--
is that the property had poultry
operation that was run by--
well, that was owned by Purdue--
run by their quote,
unquote, family farmer.
And we believe that
that was discharging
into that drainage ditch
and out to where we sampled.
There was also the cattle
operation, which had probably
some impact on the water.
But what was interesting was--
as part of the Clean
Water Act lawsuit,
we had to notify them that
we were planning to sue them.
And at some point, what you
see on the aerial photo--
as you can see, you
know, tiny there,
but basically the cattle were
then moved from the cattle
grazing area down
in the far right--
if we the looked on
the previous photo,
where you see all the cattle
markings from them in the two
lower right fields--
to a feeder that's
up in the top there.
So you can see the cows
parked around some hay
bales or a feeder with
a bunch of hay on there
to create the impression
that the cows weren't just
over to the far right.
They were more by this
ditch even though--
and that's just
something we randomly
picked up on Google Earth.
So when I'm in
deposition with them,
and I ask them, well, where
do the cows hang out--
and they tell me, oh, they
hang out all over the place.
And you can see, and
there was a whole series
of photos, as you can imagine,
from Google Earth that
show that, consistent with
the markings in these areas,
that the cows and
their feeders mostly
are in here, some in here,
and pretty rarely up in there.
And so, this is the
aerial photograph.
So this is the pile that was at
the top of that drainage ditch.
This is the ditch
that was in question.
And so, we had the
Google Earth photos,
and then we also
had aerial photos
that the water keeper
was able to get a flight
and take some of
their own photos.
And here you had
a pile which was
sort of unknown, what it
was, but it was pretty
clear from these photos that
the farmer had dug trenches
to drain what was
in those piles--
the runoff, the water that
was accumulating there,
into the farm runoff--
into the ditches that
then, ultimately,
went out to where we sampled.
Then it ultimately went out
to the waters of the US.
So again, what's the
purpose of this photo?
What's the purpose of
the previous photo?
If the purpose is to show where
the cows are, if the purpose is
to show where they
are in a given date
given the image date
from Google Earth,
if the purpose here is to show
that the farmer had indeed--
that there was drainage
coming from this pile, which
turned out to be--
it was actually sewage sludge.
Unrelated case, but
the farmer was also
stockpiling sewage sludge.
So it's material that's rich in
nutrients as well as probably
bacteria and pathogens.
And he had trenched this,
so is their drainage?
What's the material?
Did he intend to drain this
material into the ditch?
Those questions, I
think, it's certainly
is relevant, and fit
for that purpose,
and would be
helpful to the jury.
So this is the sampling point,
and this became an issue
for a couple of reasons.
One is whether she
was trespassing.
Two is how she took
the samples, as far
as her sterile technique.
Getting to the lab data
that we use, we had,
I think, it was
14 or 12 samples.
And she went through,
she wore gloves,
she used sealed
containers from the lab.
She kept them cold.
She had a chain of custody from
the sampling point to the lab.
And so, all of the questions
where you say, well,
do we need to hire a consultant?
Do we need to pay
somebody a lot of money
to come in from another
state and take a sample,
or is it sufficient to
have somebody that's
got sort of the requisite
training that would otherwise
disqualify the sample?
So if she didn't know
about sterile technique,
or if she hadn't
worn sterile gloves,
or protected the integrity
of the sampling containers,
those would be things that
would call into question
the reliability of the results.
But the court ended up
admitting the sample results--
didn't question the results--
because she was able to answer
questions on her cross-exam
that she had done
all of the things
that would otherwise
disqualify those results.
And so, there was some question
about whether there was flow
that the defendant said that
there wasn't ever flow--
that there was barely
ever water here.
And so, these
pictures, obviously
came into play for that.
This is at that
public access point,
and obviously that was
helpful for that purpose.
I just put this picture in here.
I think Nathan--
I don't know if Nathan
has an interest.
Some of the work that
I do on fracking--
and I do a lot of work with
the folks down in Texas
and the people in Pennsylvania.
And so, it's difficult
to see in this example.
I just quickly pulled it off
YouTube, but with FLIR camera,
it's not unlike, in some sense,
a standard photograph, which
we've seen some
examples of, but it's
an $80,000 piece of equipment.
But with such a camera,
you can see emissions
from this equipment that you
can't see with the naked eye.
And so, there's a piece
of equipment here,
and you can see all
this billowing out
of there, which is primarily
volatile organic chemicals--
things like benzene,
and toluene,
and you name it from
these storage tanks.
And so, when you look
at-- whether you're
looking at climate
change impacts,
or whether you're
looking at health
and environmental impacts, or
all of the above, you know,
you have these tanks.
You walk up close to them.
You can smell them.
But they are vented
to the atmosphere.
They're not being regulated.
And you have people--
typically with
respect to fracking,
you have people that are
living in conjunction with them
in close proximity.
You might have a swimming
pool or a playground
in somebody's side yard
that's within a few hundred
feet of some of these tanks.
And so, again,
what's the purpose?
Is the purpose to show that,
in fact, there are emissions?
Is the purpose to show
that the four-year-old is
having breathing problems as
a result of these emissions?
From my perspective, if the
purpose is to show emissions,
you have someone testify.
Five minutes?
That's perfect-- you know,
what the FLIR camera does,
how it does it,
and what it shows--
which I think would validate
that there are admissions.
If the purpose was to show that
somebody was having breathing
problems or was getting cancer
from that, you would probably
also have, for example, some
other grab samples, some air
testing, that actually
qualified or quantified
the amounts of benzene, and
toluene, and other things that
are in the air that would
then be corroborated
with this visual evidence
that says, in fact,
there is something
coming from the tank.
And we're picking it
up in the front yard
of my client or the
person that's complaining.
So I think that
this is an example.
Unfortunately, it's
out of the hands--
financially out of the hands
of most people at this point,
but it's a really
powerful tool with respect
to not just health but
also climate change
issues with methane
leaks and other things.
This is an example
outside Pittsburgh
that I'm looking at right now.
This is from modeling
that was done--
and this is cancer risk
based on Coke emissions.
And so, I'm looking at a
case around a Coke plant
outside Pittsburgh,
where you have
people that are living in
the shadows of this huge Coke
plant, one of the few
remaining in Pittsburgh.
And this is sort of the
rigorous data that's
looked at based on air
emission data and modeling
of those emissions, where you
can see these huge cancer risks
as a result of the emissions.
This is another
thing that's going
on in that same community,
which is this is--
I think this is called--
I forget the name
of this device,
but it's one of these internet
of things connected devices
that looks at air quality.
So is it is it
lab-certified data?
I mean, this example
it said 200 high.
The air quality is bad.
Again, am I trying to show
that half the neighborhood has
asthma because of
this, or am I trying
to show that they have
decreased the property values
because their air
quality is bad,
or am I just trying to show that
the Coke ovens are impacting
the air quality locally?
And then I have the other
data, the previous data,
where I have modeling
to show the real nature
and extent of risk and injury.
This is another similar device.
These are guys that I've
talked to about trying
to use in some of
my cases, where
you could take for a couple
hundred, $200 or $300.
This one's called a uHoo, and
you could distribute these
throughout a neighborhood
and show that, for example,
the pattern of emissions.
You could show that the
emissions, or the air
pollutants, are at the highest
level near the facility
and decay as you get farther
out from the facility.
What you might also
try to show are things
like the pattern of emissions.
So a lot of times,
industries will--
you know, smart on their part--
will wait until
between 2:00 and 5:00
in the morning to
let things fly.
And so, I have a
case in Michigan
where the refinery
there is alleged,
by the people living near it--
between 2:00 and
5:00 in the morning,
they smell the rotten eggs.
They smell the chemicals,
and they wake up
with difficulty breathing.
And so, again, you put something
like this inside your house
or just outside your house.
It's capturing data.
And is the data being used to
prove that you got lymphoma
or leukemia from
that, or is it being
used to show that every night,
at between 2:00 and 4:00,
you get a spike?
Whatever that number is, it may
not be scientifically credible
to the 0.00, but does it show
that there is some pattern
that--
or when the weather changes,
that you get a shift,
and that weather is
consistent with winds
blowing from the facility
to your point of testing.
So again, it really gets
back to this question
about what is it that you're
intending to use the data for?
This is-- what do I
have, like, two minutes?
This is another example, when
I gave a talk with Public Lab,
that someone was doing
in New York City, which
I thought was really great--
was that they were using--
they were giving
low-income people
that were in subsidized housing
these connected thermometers.
And they were collecting
data from their homes,
so that in the winter
they could see where
people were living in sub--
you know, in freezing--
or maybe not freezing
but uninhabitable conditions
in their homes that were not
being properly--
so they're living
in public housing or
subsidized housing,
and they're not being
treated properly.
And so, it's really
a simple-- you know,
it's just a temperature test
with a GPS tag that could show
these homes--
and I guess a time tag as
well, so time and temperature
are essentially
that we could do,
for the most part, with our
smartphones these days--
that set up legal
arguments for these people
to say that they're not
being treated properly
and that they need
adequate housing.
So to sort of bring this
a little bit to a head,
better doesn't always mean
more, and sometimes more data,
even if it's
qualitative data, can
be better to prove
a certain point,
depending on what that point is.
And so, there's this
balance, or tension,
between quality and quantity of
data that largely relates back
to money.
So sort of to give
you an example,
this is that Coke
facility in the top right.
You can see part of it.
And if we were to
go and take samples
throughout the neighborhood,
they all cost money.
If we were to take
them with a PhD
from the University
of Pittsburgh,
it would cost even more money.
And so, the question
becomes what is it
that we are trying to prove?
And if we're trying to
prove that the levels of air
pollutants are highest
near the facility,
and they decay as
you get farther away,
and that they spike at
night, that that may be--
a certain level of
data quality might
be suitable for
that versus trying
to prove that someone's lung
cancer or some other health
issues were a result
of that exposure.
And I guess the converse
is it may, in times--
and I think this
is a good example--
be better to have more data
of an arguable lesser quality
than to have rigorous
sampling done on three houses
but not to have that
full spectrum that
shows what's happening as you
get farther and farther away,
because you focused your
time, effort, and ultimately
your money on sampling
those things that
were located where you had
one sick person and that's it.
Then you get into a question--
OK, I've got a great number
outside this person's house,
but I'm not sure how it
relates back to the facility,
and I'm not sure how the
facility is impacting everybody
else in the neighborhood.
And I think that is-- so I
think this is my last slide.
Obviously, more money
you pay for people
with degrees, and consultants,
and for lab testing--
you can save money with some
of these techniques, citizen
science, some of these
taking your own samples
with the appropriate
training and technique--
using some of these
connected devices,
using some photography
and FLIR cameras.
More money doesn't
always mean better,
but it tends to
mean that you've got
better numbers, more
precise numbers, that
are more reliable.
But again, the question
is what is your purpose?
If your purpose is
to show you know
that the source of the
pollution is impacting
the neighborhood
in a broad sense,
you can probably get by with
some data of lesser rigor
and that's lesser expense.
If you're trying
to prove someone's
been exposed for how
long at what level
precisely to show
that they got sick,
obviously the standards
are increased,
and the level of scientific
rigor is heightened as well.
So I think that's it
for me, and I'll pass--
I'll answer any questions.
I'll receive applause.
The question was to
what extent trespassing
on people's land and drones--
it's a good question.
Drones are, you know,
for some people, maybe
not so new, but as far as
people like me, a newer thing.
But, I mean, drones
are a great--
I mean, huge.
Like, the aerial photos that
were taken with a full flight--
like, having to rent a
plane and all that stuff,
it could be done with
drones very easily--
get even better
quality pictures.
Drones are a huge, huge
benefit to the citizen science
operation.
I mean, they have drones that
can also take air samples
and things like that, so
the ability to get data
cheaply, and efficiently, and
effectively is a big thing.
As far as trespassing
goes, in my opinion,
you never want to trespass.
You never want to
represent someone
who's going to have
somebody else saying, well,
you trespassed.
By the same token,
I have had cases
where people trespass on
the land, and took a sample,
and went home.
And as a lawyer, I
have an obligation
to disclose the fact
that they took a sample--
the result of that sampling.
And aside from any allegations
or claims of criminal trespass,
if the data is
reliable-- if they
can't impugn what the person
did-- that they somehow
adulterated the
sample, then the sample
should be admissible for
the purpose of showing
what the sample shows, right?
So there could be a dispute
about whether there's
some criminal trespass,
which I think largely there's
no impact from, but in general,
the answer is if you can do it
with a drone, and you
can take pictures,
if you can get a
court order to get
a sample on the property,
that's a much better way
to do it than trespassing.
A lot of people don't
understand the first thing
you have to do is make a
good case to the judge.
So judges stand between
you and the jury
as far as scientific evidence--
as far as any evidence, right.
And so, you first have to make
a good argument to the judge
that the data is reliable,
fit for its intended purpose,
and that it will
assist the jury.
What a jury will
believe is oftentimes
different than what
a judge will believe,
so something like a FLIR
camera that shows visually
the stream of
pollution coming off
may be very compelling
to a jury even
if I'm talking about leukemia.
It may not be very
compelling to a judge
if I'm talking about leukemia,
because it doesn't give you
a number.
It just tells you that
there's stuff coming off,
and I have an expert that says
that stuff is this stuff that
may cause leukemia.
But it's still not 20 parts
per billion of benzene,
and that's ultimately what
I need to show according
to most judges, right.
So I think, again, it's
a very wide spectrum.
It would vary hugely from
hugely from judge to judge,
and there's not any one answer.
I can tell you, that as far as
epidemiology goes, generally,
what courts require-- if I want
to show that an exposure caused
my client's leukemia,
for example,
I would need to have a
study that showed a greater
than two-fold increased risk.
So I have more than a
doubling of the risk
to a 95% confidence interval.
So to eliminate the no risk
and to be at least a doubling
at that confidence interval,
and that essentially
goes to this argument that
it's more probably than not
caused by the exposure.
Does that makes sense?
OK.